Martine Ricard est une femme condamnée à
63 ans elle devra vivre avec la douleur
pour le restant de ses jours
capable
la lettre turquoise avait un problème
d'incontinence à l'effort pour lequel il
existe une solution médicale une
bandelette urinaire mais les choses se
sont compliquées le dispositif à perforé
son urètre sonnerie une opération en
juin 2021 dans un centre d'expertise du
Québec tout juste mis sur pied par le
ministère de la Santé et des Services
sociaux justement pour gérer ce genre de
complications mais tous ces mots se sont
aggravés
c'est les jambes
la plus de force dans les jambes dans
les hanches la douleur dans les hanches
dans la fesse dans les zen
c'est ce puis ça c'est des mots que vous
aviez pas avant l'été 2021
[Musique]
un petit treillis de polypropylène qui
ressemble à un filet un dispositif conçu
pour régler les désagréments liés aux
futurs à l'effort l'installation est
simple chirurgie d'un jour l'enjeu n'est
pas d'installer la bandelette mais de la
retirer quand des complications
surviennent elle a été conçue pour
rester pour se fondre dans les tissus
dans les muscles parfois même dans les
eaux et c'est bien là le problème
enlever une bandelette est une opération
hautement délicate et invasive qui peut
provoquer des dommages irréversibles il
faut plus qu'il fasse ça
vous avez perdu confiance
Ricard a tenté auprès d'un expert
américain le docteur Dionysos Véronique
l'opération de la dernière chance
bonjour Martine
ça va
ça va décourager un peu parce que j'ai
pas eu l'opération finalement de docteur
Véronique a refusé
lors d'un suivi médical dont nous avons
obtenu copie l'une des médecins qui a
opéré Martin Ricard reconnaît que les
muscles ont vécu un traumatisme
reconnaît aussi que la douleur actuelle
de sa patiente est liée du moins en
partie à la chirurgie de retrait alors
quel espoir aujourd'hui pour Martine
Ricard
sans appel le docteur Véronique rapporte
à boire opéré quelques 300 femmes du
Québec à ce jour sur un groupe de
soutien sur les médias sociaux des
femmes se disent satisfaites de leur
opération auprès de l'urologue américain
qui est d'avis que seul un petit nombre
de chirurgiens dans le monde devrait
opérer les retraites bandelettes
au Québec le président de l'association
des urologues montre du doigt le
ministère de la Santé et des Services
sociaux
tout le monde est à effectif réduit puis
là on nous demande d'en faire plus on
peut pas une experte en centre
d'expertise lui aurait confié
les docteurs ont peur les patients ont
peur il y a une certaine peur on dirait
de traiter ça par courriel le ministère
répond que les médecins ont la
compétence pour opérer les retraites
bandelettes et que des travaux sont en
cours pour consolider l'organisation du
réseau le Ministère reconnaît que le
recrutement a été difficile mais précise
avoir mobilisé à ce jour plus de 77 % du
personnel nécessaire dans les centres
d'expertise le ministère n'assure pas le
suivi de la formation des médecins je
sais que je vais avoir un down puis que
ça va si ça remplir il va être
drôlement de l'aide à mourir on ne doit
quand on était que regarde la chirurgie
auprès du docteur Véronique en soi
au-delà de 20 000 dollars Québec ne
rembourse plus depuis que le ministère a
désigné les centres d'expertise
l'espoir de Martinerie car aujourd'hui
ça brûle c'est que son histoire trouvée
co auprès des femmes et des décideurs
ici Marie-Eve Trudel Radio-Canada
Trois-Rivières
qui dort